i often talk about the importance
of learning and teaching media literacy
media criticism epistemology the
thinking arts
so to speak and i also talk about the
absolute and total lack of those
in our country among large swaths of the
population
today i'm going to go through one
90-second news max clip newsmax is this
kind of radical alternative to fox news
and we're going to try to look at how
many lies how many distortions how many
baseless assumptions can we find
so this is it's actually kind of hard
for me to tell you what this segment is
about
i guess the segment is sort of about
so-called cancel culture type content
and um the segment claims that the left
is nothing short of
marxist authoritarian dictators of some
kind
so let's take it piece by piece and
you're going to see how quickly
there builds a pyramid of so much that
is
wrong in this segment and because
there's so much
unless you are really armed with
critical thinking faculties
just by the sheer number of deceptions
and misstatements here
you'll probably fall for some of it so
let's begin with the first part of this
here today our culture this
is happening marxists have used the
hollow shell of the democratic party
to ascend to power okay so there are no
marxists in the american democratic
party
the closest you might get in the senate
is bernie who calls himself a democratic
socialist
maybe he was a democratic socialist in
his younger years
he advocates for standard northern
european social democracy
not marxism there's no marxism in the
u.s senate in the house
okay aoc calls herself a democratic
socialist
there are some other members of congress
who use that term they aren't marxists
and certainly no marxists have any power
in the united states they've not taken
over the democratic party
in any way shape or form so already the
segment is lined up
with a bogus framing a bogus base to
this pyramid of disinformation
let's keep going and do what they have
always wanted to do
in this country and what they do in
every country destroy the history
and culture of the nation that they have
taken over no history has been destroyed
and certainly no culture has been
destroyed culture evolved
culture is something that evolves over
time a politically
economically intellectual culture all
participants in a culture
shape it either explicitly or implicitly
it's essentially a meaningless
fear-mongering statement meant to
resonate in what we know are the
fear-oriented brains
of conservatives next clip this year
alone we have seen kermit the frog
mr potato head dr seuss star wars
characters
pancake syrup butter and beloved sports
teams logos
banned erased from history now this one
is really a doozy
none of that is true in any real sense
and
this is a gish gallop the whole segment
is a gish gala but this set of examples
is a it's a it's a gish gallop within a
gish gallop
kermit the frog some episodes have
depictions
of native americans and middle eastern
people that are not great
and some muppet show episodes now have a
warning at the beginning they're not
banned they have a warning at the
beginning
mr potato head had its franchise name
changed to potato head both mr
and mrs potato head still exist dr seuss
we've been talking about the publishing
company decided not to keep publishing
six books due to stereotypes of asian
people in them
nothing is banned star wars characters i
guess he's referring to the mandalorian
star
gina carano who was fired because she
implied that being a republican today is
like being jewish during the holocaust
and a private company decided what's
good for them it's not very marxist for
private for-profit companies
to be allowed to do whatever they want
but that is market capitalism that we
have in the united states
pancake syrup is aunt jemima syrup being
renamed because the imagery of aunt
jemima is quite
crass today given how it stereotypes
black americans
the syrup is still around it's just
called pearl milling it's it's
uh not on jemima anymore butter i don't
even know what he's talking about i
wasn't even able to find anything on
that one
sports team logos yes you know
washington redskins with a caricature
of a red-skinned native american
stereotype
um it just doesn't it's unflattering and
it's inappropriate at this point and the
team decided this is bad for us so we're
going to change the team name and
now the host says these aren't merely
decisions by private companies
these are not simply marketing choices
of private companies
we want to emphasize this joe biden's
white house endorses
these modern-day book burnings the white
house the most powerful seat in our land
biden broke with long-standing tradition
and refused to acknowledge
dr seuss on his birthday this very week
he refused to recommend that children
read beloved dr seuss books
so he implies joe biden has weighed in
on that list of things he gave
and joe biden hasn't joe biden went
along with what read across america day
did
which is they don't include dr seuss
biden hasn't endorsed any of the other
stuff the guy listed he hasn't even
mentioned most of it at all
uh one more clip here amazon then
stopped selling certain dr seuss titles
and publishers halted printing them
entirely here are real screenshots from
an
ebay user getting blocked for trying to
sell a dr
seuss book because it is and i quote
offensive
material we verified these images are
real
what's also real real shocking is
that hitler's mind conf is still
available for sale
on ebay this is a book literally about
racism
this is a book literally calling for
book burnings
you cannot make this up so then he
raises amazon
should amazon not be allowed to do what
they want i mean
is it is the argument from free market
capitalist newsmax
that amazon shouldn't be allowed amazon
should be
forced to do something ebay should be
forced
to sell books who would force them the
government that's not small government
concern
conservatism and arguably his only maybe
good point comes at the end
which is why is hitler's book still
available shouldn't there be some
consistency here
i personally think there should be that
being said
it's ultimately the decision of ebay so
there is essentially
nothing in this rant that is accurate or
relevant to the real world
but people watch this stuff and they
fall hook line and sinker for it
let me know what you think we'll have
more coverage of these
types of segments on the david pakman
show instagram page find us there at
david pakman show
find me on instagram david.pacman as
well
one of our sponsors today is helix sleep
and it's a sponsor
i'm thrilled about because i sleep on a
helix mattress
at home and it's just the perfect
mattress one of the best things about
helix is
you don't have to guess which mattress
do i need which one will be good for me
you take their famous sleep quiz on
their website you tell them your body
type
your sleeping position your back pain
issues you might have
and they will pair you with a mattress
that will be perfect for you
i took the sleep quiz the mattress they
suggested was exactly what i needed
i often get too hot at night the
mattress keeps me cool
it's not too soft it's not too firm the
texture is right
and i've just been getting way better
sleep you only buy a mattress
every decade or so don't get stuck with
something that's not perfect for you and
all helix mattresses come with a 10 year
warranty
and they'll even come to your house and
pick it up within a hundred days if you
don't love it
but i think you will all of my viewers
will get up to 200
off your order and you'll get two super
premium pillows
for free when you go to the link right
underneath this video